thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a poetic
wild ride with Stevo we've got Maynard's
James Keenan of tool A Perfect Circle
Puscifer and I have to say I've been a
fan of this guy for considerably more
than half of my life I've always known
him to be so mysterious uh such an
enigma Larger than Life like just a rock
star he would say just a poet but man I
don't think we've ever seen me uh do a
podcast with somebody I was such a fan
of which makes for just an incredibly
entertaining experience which includes
the most embarrassing moment I think
I've ever experienced on the podcast and
uh if you're not going to want to miss
it it's pure gold
um also I want you to know that tomorrow
as this comes out on Friday March 31st
Puscifer is releasing
existential Reckoning rewired which is a
track by track reimagining of
existential Reckoning their last album
that is available Friday March 31st be
sure to get it and scrap on your seat
belts for this one let's get into it
okay so we won't waste any time check
check recording every camera recording
of the camera oh it's you're blowing
your shot with that blind not being down
yeah that's not the blindness
you're doing great
there you go
yeah now you're not so shooting into the
light
all right
ladies and gentlemen Maynard James
Keenan where
[Laughter]
yeah dude uh you've met Scott Randolph
this is Vinnie what's up dude sir nice
to meet you and uh we're here in Arizona
thank you so much for inviting us out
here man what an honor
it's an honor to have you here watching
people storm your overly branded bus
yeah it's not so subtle my tour bus is
obnoxiously wrapped with my face and
name and I haven't uh I have regretted
that at times
um never regret yeah you guys sit there
just dripping with anxiety to to look at
the rap on oh yeah I was like to drive
around with my name on a bus I would
just be folding in on myself
you guys don't put tool on the side of
yours intro
was there ever
ever no no Puscifer nope nothing no I
think at some point we did maybe Perfect
Circle and it was like never again like
that was
1999 or 2002 or something like
what a dumb idea
I am don't expect to wrap any buses
again in the future for what it's worth
um yeah I was dying to ask about that if
there was ever a tour bus
we had we had um Paul Frank wrapped uh
uh Perfect Circle bus at some point that
was kind of cool okay how many tour
buses are you guys taking out with tool
when you guys are going around [__] uh
I would be guessing uh 10 7 8 wow you
guys each get one
yeah we finally got to that age where
it's like I'm kind of I don't I kind of
like you but not that often I don't want
to breathe in your farts at night no
yeah no
um yeah but you know then I go right
back on the road with Puscifer and it's
20 people
20 person bus we're all just crammed on
top of each other wow see you know it's
good to
to know what it's like
I I could have guessed that you wouldn't
have been big on wrapping buses because
you're notoriously private and um and
here I am on camera being private I know
that's it that's the thing is um As I
understood it you know in the early days
of tool like you guys basically
at all cost avoided being on camera like
avoided doing interviews like didn't
like you were pretty unseen
and uh you've opened up over the years
like is is there a philosophy to being
less private well I mean I just
yeah there's many layers to that uh
friends get together we write some songs
I write some poems and sing to them
it's not that special it's not on a wire
tripping over yourself to come taste my
skin you know it just seems weird to
have that kind of a you know that
reaction over some [__] poems this
seems weird right uh so it's out of
balance for what seems normal all right
but also just like your private life
should be
you know kind of your private life right
but then
you know flipping that around like
trying to don't don't photograph me
um then you just have to start listening
to what you said yourself and go am I so
important
right not really that important
but at the same time you like your
privacy so sure when you're
when you're serving food yeah uh
people are there to have the food but
when you're not serving food I shouldn't
be bugged about recipes right and that
that makes sense
um
with that
with the writing the poems
it it's crazy to me that that you seem
to strive to not really play a role in
making the music you want the music done
and then well depends on the project
right yeah so you know historically I
wrote a lot earlier with tool we all
wrote together I would bring a piece
everybody brings something to it uh same
thing with Puscifer with Billy he wrote
a bunch of stuff he just had a bunch of
stuff written so that was kind of the
process that we just kind of went with
with perfect circle well with the
Puscifer there's a lot more
collaboration going on between Matt and
Karina and I uh tool like I said early
days we were all writing but as you get
older stubborn more successful and the
ego start to swell and all four of us
can't fit our heads in one room you know
one of us has to back out and just let
that fight occur and then wait for the
chips to fall and then go okay
I'll write some poems to that yeah so
you get the music and then you and
notoriously the music can take a long
time to get to you
and uh and then when it does get to you
you turn around
because you're trying to react to the
music yeah yeah and generally that's
that's how I write I've been
recently I've been working in in logic
finally unlocked
the logic Magic Door where I can come up
with rhythms and Melodies that are just
kind of you know sketches on a napkin
and I'm able to write a lot more music
in that way because I'm not a drummer
I'm not a guitar player I can play
guitar
I can barely tune a guitar and that's
how I used to write it as on a bass
um but I just kind of like because
there's better bass players because
there's better guitar players that's
just going to let them do that but now
that I've unlocked just little
uh tool no pun intended and logic I'm
like I have this new thing now where
um I can't have I can't finish my coffee
unless I write at least a beat or a
melody
in logic and then send that off to Matt
and Karina and Puscifer go here here's
my here's my morning coffee so like at
least three a week
I send them something so I'd like this
folder of like 40
things I've been working on over time
and I'm sending some of those to if it
sounds like it's leaning toward Perfect
Circle it's leaning toward tool I'll
send them those away but usually you
just get crickets back from those guys
so
like that's a cute riff
stay in your [__] Lane nice
um with with uh
you know the Puscifer just the name of
the band and V is for a vagina like
there there's so much what are you
implying well I'm I'm uh
I'm observing uh the naughtiness and
there's been like Tool's been naughty
like from the get-go and there's been
issues with uh with with like censorship
and stuff yeah how much of uh
like how much of it is like oh let's you
know
like what I'm trying to think of my
question here like I'm emotionally 11. I
like that I I like that and I relate to
that like how much did it screw you over
with success oh right I mean you guys
almost tried to not be successful it
seems like oh man Puscifer we've shipped
the first record V is for vagina shipped
we were doing great it all went out from
the time that we started recording V is
for vagina until the day that we
actually released it the record industry
[__] collapsed so all the record
scores were open when we started
recording when we released Tower and
virgin had all closed like all those Mom
and Pops had closed we were stuck with
Target Best Buy uh Kmart and Target sent
our albums back because it said vagina
on it yeah I was like what we pissed you
you don't like vagina yeah I love them I
know it's kind of like us with the hot
sauce like Amazon's like dude you guys
are doing great we want to put you on
the front page our hot sauce is called
hot sauce for your butthole
and they're like can you change the word
butthole it seems like no [__] way
you figure out a way to not have a
butthole we'll change the name
then we could talk yeah right so I mean
there's kind of a parallel there but
when you guys I mean you guys relied on
that income for with Walmart and Target
and all those places right yeah and then
all of a sudden you're like [__] what do
I do yeah I mean because that implicit
was an independent man so like I wrote
the check for all those all that vinyl
yeah not only pay for the vinyl to be
made but to have the vinyl shipped back
to me and then ran a [__] Warehouse
to put it in and we still we sold it all
eventually but like that was scary like
to have you know 80 000 pieces of vinyl
shipped back to you what year was it
vinyl with that I love that you said
piece of vinyl yeah it's a real uh what
year was that was that before all the
success no that was that was a poster
for that was uh
2007 2006. no yes 2007 when not when
everything kind of fell apart [__] yeah
so what do you do how did you get rid of
all those records you know we just kept
touring and kept making records and
doing [__] and they finally sold we just
got I just recently this last year we
got a whole new run of you know color
variants on it those are still moving so
it took it's just I don't know I'm
[__] stubborn so don't take no for an
answer and yeah just keep going
what is your opinion
of record labels
like in general like no pressure well no
I mean
I've never sold music so so I you know
I'm pretty ignorant but I've always
understood that
in order to make it big you need the
record label
this is this is all in this is very
individual based this is all very
specific to an individual artist most
artists are some uh woe is me somebody
touched my butthole gonna bring it back
to your house uh
when I was kids now I gotta be up in
front of people acting like a [__]
um no idea how to do business no idea
how to organize anything but you're
incredible at whatever this art is that
you've developed over the years dancing
around in front of a mirror with your
[__] brush right
um so that you need somebody
like a manager or a label to kind of
handle all that business side of things
in theory but if you have a head for
that
you really don't need a label
you just don't if you understand how to
run a business
but now we're back to like most artists
right no clue
they can barely get up before 11. right
there's just not it's just not in their
nature right
um I come from a farming Community back
in Michigan
you know I'm a martial artist so there's
there's things you got to do during the
day to get to prepare for that okay just
have a big breakfast and go run on the
mat and start doing Jiu Jitsu right so
I'm up at 5 30. just because that's just
my nature
um I have I plan
um
so I don't know I think labels aren't
neces what it comes down to is
um individual
jobs within promoting an album that I
might not be able to handle like actual
marketing and actual like distribution
mailing lists and all that kind of [__]
that like there's there's various
there's various ad agencies and and
promotional institutions and marketing
people that have that covered and then
there's the logistics of you know
warehousing and shipping and dates and
deadlines and stuff that I have a head
for but I delegate that to my wife
because she's really good at it
um so we kind of you know kind of manage
it that way so if you can do that do
that yeah and do you want to be as big
as you know whatever the biggest star is
nowadays well then you're going you have
to be part of the system 100 if you're
going to be Beyonce you you have to be
tapped in because everybody wants their
fingers in that pie and that way
it gets big because the bigger the pie
the bigger your slice right right so
there's that but at the level of
puscifer's operating at you know we're
playing to like two thousand three
thousand people
it's it's a decent number of people to
play to but it's still
you still have to manage those margins
right and try to talk to them try to
talk to some dude and some rock man that
you know about the word margins see how
that goes
right Scott's my guy yeah for for all of
that
um how long have you been married
uh 10 years wow I should get married on
leap year day so
two and a half years
okay three one one three
that's is that right because that's my
that's my sober birthday
uh on leap year we got I think I thought
it was a leap year that year but we
actually got it was on 29th of February
12. yeah okay yes I thought I thought I
got sober on a leap year and so then
like four years later I was like dude I
got someone to leap year like that
wasn't a leap year that year
I always thought I was right leap year
baby so you're bad at math yeah and
you're in charge of yeah
for sure
six other
you're uh just about exactly 10 years
older than I am okay and you've been
married for 10 years I've been engaged
for five years okay I'm getting married
this year awesome congratulations ten
years behind you on that too all right
is this the first time you've ever said
that out loud I I mean I would like to
be married and it's here
I'm gonna be doing a lot of crazy things
this year are you gonna get married with
tits
I think that's gonna be the final test
for my fiance but for my next tour I'm
putting together this really wild show
called uh Steve has gone too far to her
and uh there I'm gonna think of the
implants I'm not thinking of it I'm
gonna absolutely do it okay
I don't want to show you my Amazon cart
right now but like I literally was
buying you know all everything going on
I was like I gotta bring back the tits
nice because I used to wear them in 97
and I ordered them and I got this it's
like weird like it's a whole sleeve like
you have to put it on like a vest and
it's tits like these are these feel like
this is like stripper tits they're like
yeah they're silicone but they're like
right here so put it on and my wife's
like what the [__] are you wearing it
looks like headlights like this
Tijuana boob job it's awful I'm told
that that uh I can fit D's or double d's
with like proper breast surgery
go go seek up
you think yeah it'll look better yeah it
seems look a lot better dude I mean dude
there's just something about d and or
double dude might as well go double yeah
that's that's good I probably shouldn't
talk about that in front of your wife
right that you even know what a d-cup
looks like right that's true let's just
edit this part out
I am that's what my girl is is not super
thrilled about about that whole plan but
I'm only gonna have them for like three
months okay and that's just for the the
production period of the show logistic
Minds I'm kind of going okay give
yourself time to do the thing heal from
the thing get healthy from the thing and
then go do the tour well right I'm not
touring with the tits I'm just doing
like but I do a multimedia tour so so
there's everything gets shot the show
gets put together and then the tour goes
on okay as a multimedia thing okay I
feel like you got to do at least one
meet and greet with the tits though I'm
gonna do lot of things with the tits bro
okay so that's not what this is about
I'm just I'm just riffing here if you
have the teeth on the super low cut
right
just a not just barely nipple right just
a little bit of areola but make sure
there's a camera
see how many guys so that you're
watching dudes like coming to shake your
hand and they're like
the eye contact issue I got a whole
white board
[Laughter]
what can I say man I got plans I got a
lot of plans and you gotta have plans
especially when it comes to your health
your diet is the most important thing
man that is why I go with athletic
greens specifically ag1 from athletic
greens which is the most comprehensive
convenience supplement you can get it is
delicious it's loaded with 75 different
vitamins minerals Whole Foods sourced
superfoods adaptogens probiotics I mean
it they put more good stuff in there
than can be believed and again it is
delicious you dump a scoop in your pint
of water to get hydrated at the
beginning of the day and you have filled
in all of the gaps in your diet you've
helped your gut health your cognitive
health I mean dude it's just good for
everything I swear by it I love it and
if you go to athleticgreens.com Stevo
they will give you an entire year supply
of vitamin D immune boosting and five
convenient travel packs of the ag1 I
speak of with your first purchase again
that is at athleticgreens.com
Stevo jump on it you'd be a fool not to
now let's get back to it yeah
eye contact yeah like a screensaver yeah
there's there's a lot
um did
did you know that that uh your music
was in Super Rad skate videos yeah we
were aware of that like yeah loved it
I think mostly illegally yeah but uh
most of course yeah yeah big brother got
away with murder in that regard right
there was a union Wheels video and um
both Tom Boyle and Chris Markovich had
Tunes
of yours and uh
you have an address for them
um
particularly loved that now
um so we're in Arizona where this is
where you do your wine thing like talk
to me about doomsday prepping
yeah yeah I love that is that why you
guys like bromptons because they're like
easy to pack does it have anything to do
with speaking of packing uh it is
Arizona uh
you know I think you know
part of my doomsday mindset is just
understanding
water and farming right because I think
part of it is
there's going to be there's going to be
climate changes there's going to be
weird things that happen and if you
understand the movement of the sun and
the stars and
seasons in your area
it really is about
for the reset right understanding how to
get Beyond those things and survive
Preppers I think if they're really
you know smart Preppers they're thinking
about the first 72 hours
of when [__] really goes down and just
maintaining sanity for those that period
of time and then maybe having a [__]
some kind of store of water or food or
something for a while but when it comes
to like
actual doomsday like radiation and
nuclear weapons like there's no amount
of preparing that can help you with that
that's [__] absurd like yeah there's
nothing you're going to do to to outrun
something that's that massive of a scale
but you know if you I think it's part of
like okay so I was telling you we just
we just moved our Jiu-Jitsu Academy over
um to another location
better location more square footage like
more students coming in it's going to be
it's great but part of the idea of of
self-defense training is that now I can
I can kick somebody's ass and
if you've never wrestled or done boxing
or Muay Thai or Judo before ever in your
life the idea that you're going to stop
somebody who has a little bit of that
background that's bigger or stronger or
faster than you that's kind of dumb
but what I have noticed is that people
you know short of gunshot wounds
if you come in and you're training
enough you're actually putting yourself
in a in a stressful situation
and you've if you've never had somebody
to lay on top of it you were saying like
that was that was something that was big
for you like having they just saw that
stuff that Suffocation feeling if you
become
accustomed to that feeling and you're
able to work through the stress of that
feeling of somebody
on you pressuring you will against will
and you're able to relax through that
I think when it comes to things like
end of the world scenarios just
remaining calm and clear
knowing how to
secure fresh water knowing how to like
you know where to look for food or how
to grow food when it's all said and done
that amount of
not peace of mind I guess it's kind of
peace of mind but that being able to
relax through it and accept accept the
fate and just go this is what we're
gonna do
um we just found that people are get in
weird situations that have done enough
martial arts in their life they don't
they go they don't go completely to that
Red Zone where they black out and tunnel
vision and then their limbs go numb as
much as somebody who's never done a
martial art or ever had somebody laying
on top of them or attacking them trying
to you know strangle them or whatever so
this it is kind of a you're relieving
the initial stress and the adrenaline
dump right yeah first first amount of
tricks you guys used to do with jackass
I guarantee like the first a bunch of
those you did There's you go man that
was you I don't remember
because you went right into that weird
adrenaline dump thing initially I feel
like this thing on stage open for Steve
I will black out and I won't remember
what the [__] because it's a weird
adrenaline dump and you get tunnel
vision and you know cottonmouth and all
those things but as you've done it a
couple times even though there's a thing
you've never done before
and you're worried about doing it it's
not nearly as daunting as the first time
you did it before the cameras were ever
even rolling right and there's also
a lot more of the anxiety like leading
up to it is scarier than the thing
itself right and once you've been
through that a couple times you go oh
right remind yourself of that and you're
fine breathe through it that's one of
the things we always when people are
you're new here you haven't done any of
these things that's what I was telling I
did that whole seminar just explain the
movements before the movements there's
an introduction to jiu jitsu yeah I can
show you all these things I can show you
the guard and show you all these things
but if you don't even understand how to
move your body to begin with to defend
yourself to get out of this thing right
right
survive Escape control submit
you can't submit if you have no control
over the situation and you have and you
don't have an exit strategy to just
survive right right you said that you're
making a documentary about that yeah we
filmed we filmed the seminar itself I'm
editing it together with these guys and
uh
um I'm gonna probably go back and film
some more to really detail it but just
the understanding their body movements
and things you're going to end up
encountering in a new Jiu Jitsu Academy
if you don't even understand how to move
your body and control your own weight on
the ground
now you have somebody on top of you if
you have any kind of childhood trauma
you're like you don't want to be here
you're out I used to be put on their
mattresses when I was a kid so it just
stirs that up oh yeah yeah I will bite
and [__] [__] myself I'll do anything
to get out of that situation like no
[__] questions asked yeah like I
don't give a [__] if my mom died on I'd
buy her fingers off you know fighting
doesn't work
you're shooting yourself
right I'm just down to go to that like
like I remember when I was driving to a
party one time they put me in the back
of a car bite and then like [__] stuff
yeah got it well dude people kept piling
in and then and then so like I was in
the back of the car and somebody's like
hey everybody look Scott's about to
freak out and then that just freaking me
out and I just started punching my way
out the side window I believe that
that's called triggered yeah I read it
online triggered yes so hey look
everybody's got this [__] has passed
now if you're gonna [__] yourself or
frankly if you're gonna [__] at all then
you should know about my favorite
sponsor of the Wild Ride podcast ever
which is hello tushy makers of bidets
bidets I swear by they come you attach
it to your toilet very easily it's got a
knob and that knob when you twist it it
just fires this awesome blast of water
like pressure cleaning your butthole it
leaves you so clean it reduces your your
toilet paper use it's great for the
environment you are squeaky clean and
once you use it you never go back and if
you go to hellertushi.com
Stevo then you get 10 off your order but
be sure to use the promo code stevo2
that's hellotushy.com
slash Devo and use the promo code Stevo
for 10 off your first order so that you
can
figure out what I'm talking about I
don't call this my favorite podcast
sponsor ever for no reason and that's
why you got to get over to
hellotushy.com Devo now now let's get
back to it all right
oh my God you did that to yourself yes
but you know going back to the Doomsday
prepping I feel like there's there's
this looming thing that people I'm gonna
be the
the one who survives but it's like
there's so there's so many infinite
variables about what that even means
right you're better off
tuning yourself to understanding farming
growing your own food finding fresh
water like those kind of basic things
that you would have to do I remember
watching um
The Walking Dead series and I'm watching
it just going this is cool I think the
drama you know whatever you know there's
oh look there's a zombie uh but then all
of a sudden I was like
I haven't where are they getting their
water
right right and then like the next
episode was them like literally trying
to find water
so whatever the writer did like they
were you know it's like they put that in
there like literally part of their
entire survival was like trying to find
water for an entire episode which is
probably going on
across the whole story everywhere with
people realizing that but because
there's things you just don't even write
okay your car broke down on the side of
the road is it going to be cold tonight
is it going to be hot tonight do you
have water
do you have any food like just all those
things that go through your head in the
middle of Australia when your bus breaks
down right right
um well what do you think is going to
happen and what do you think is going to
happen for like Doomsday I mean I think
that you've got like economic collapse
is right at the top of the list
um
that seems increasingly
right increasingly likely may you live
in interesting times [__] you give me
the boring yeah right Water Crisis yeah
Waters definitely water wars is a big
big one
um
climate in general uh what are the other
Mega threats
um another uh Tick Tock
another pandemic is uh likely
as far as interrupting uh just basic
Utility Systems
if if somehow the AI decides to make a
decision that is global in terms of like
right the delivery of electric or gas or
whatever let's add cyber War to the you
know cyber warfare I think is is a legit
one there was a book
um written by Neil Strauss called uh
like emergency this book could save your
life and and for writing the book Neil
Strauss uh became like like he hung out
with militia people and like all these
different like scenarios uh got like a
pilot's license I think and you know how
to get a citizenship in other countries
and like it was pretty fascinating that
um you know the learning how to ride a
motorcycle because when
uh the [__] hits the fan everybody's
trying to get out you've got all the
traffic but the motorcycles can split
Lanes yeah it makes a lot of sense
unless you live in some place that's
like a small town of 500 people right
you're already out of that awful
situation right yeah that's why I moved
here
just because I mainly because I didn't
resonate with a large city it just
didn't I'm from a small town
so I moved back out here because I have
access to a large city to do the work I
can do with with the band but like I
moved out here to get away from sure
just that just that energy that was I
don't I wasn't raised with that energy
so you know I have
like wine I have Farms we have Gardens
and greenhouses and I raise ducks and
quail and
you know that's just that's just who I
am
um so if you understand how to keep
Quail alive and keep ducks or chickens
alive
got food right you raise Quail for the
eggs yeah we have these in the meat uh
no the meat uh I have a hard time with
that I can't I can't kill the Ducks we
tried that like I was like okay raise
these ducks uh from babies and you know
it came time to like okay these ones
have to go and like I had nightmares for
a week
so we have a bunch of these ducks that
don't lay eggs that are just like
freeloaders they don't pay any rent
are you completely off the grid pretty
much no no no no no and I think that
again going back to the purpose thing
that is an absolute absurd myth that
you're going to be able to live off the
grid for any length of time if there's
going to be some kind of materials that
you need to trade for you can't grow
your entire thing by yourself generally
speaking you have to be a master at that
stuff in the right location to deal with
the the seasonal changes and all that
you're going to end up having to trade
something with somebody for some kind of
thing to get a job done there's that dog
food or resources or tools or whatever
yes you're gonna you're gonna
you know fuel even if that might be at
that point where like there is no there
are you know you have to figure out how
to do that well that's where there's
that's where distillation comes in you
know you're you know figuring out how to
like create a fuel A flammable material
from using wood to distill some kind of
sugar-based so are you reading books on
this [__] like at night before it's just
logic it's just simple logic of like
looking at what you do in your life or
you're going to just eat the raw food
because somebody gonna need heat or you
need to like cook your food
okay well then you're going to need some
kind of a fuel source to cook your food
okay well then what you know what kind
of you know it's just all those things
unravel just logically and logistically
in my head to go okay well
uh move to a small town learned how to
grow food and feed ducks and uh quail
and how about bunkers are you under
those I have a well you just saw one of
them like that's that thing is
temperature because their bunker for me
is is a place where we can regulate
temperature okay if I have to live in
that thing in the middle of summer in
the middle of winter it's going to
maintain a certain temperature so it's a
comfortable living setting
I thought bunker had to be underground
that's what I thought well the lower
part of that okay there's a roof that's
easily three feet thick and it's
surrounded on three sides by ground so
you roll those doors down and that is
technically it's a bunker it's not it's
not buried underground like you have to
go through a tunnel to get to it that's
I can't even imagine the psychological
mess you would be living in one of those
for about a month I don't disagree that
it might be unpleasant to spend that
much time in a bunker but I really like
the idea of having a bunker and the only
problem is how are you going to pay for
it and I have your answer you start
killing it in the e-commerce game that's
how you become prepared for disasters by
making money and how do you do that well
you start off by having something to
sell like Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole or the excruciatingly hot
stevos butthole Destroyer now I sell
this stuff on Amazon I sell it at
stevo.com and that's what's great about
this sponsorship station it's how I sell
everything online now if you're selling
on Etsy Amazon your own website doesn't
matter ship station is one easy to use
interface that brings all of these
platforms into just one thing and it
also brings in all of your methods of
shipping like the United States Post
Office FedEx UPS it's all in one
interface and they give you access to
the the best rates which are normally
reserved for Fortune 500 companies and
it is so easy you get an order and boom
print out your label you put the label
on the box and it's out the door
shipping paid for it it's that easy it's
ship station it's time to make ship
happen so you can get prepared for
doomsday okay now even better you get a
60-day free trial if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Steve
60-day free trial that's a big deal man
you're going to find out how easy it is
to kill it in the e-commerce game I mean
dude go to shipstation.com and use the
promo code Stevo and hand the god that
is how I sell all of my merch that is
how I ship every order with ship station
I love them you need to use them
shipstation.com promo code Stevo let's
get back to it yeah so that was
strategically built to where like it
picks up wind and the it just picks it
just makes sure that the if the power
grid goes out
for a period of time because I'm
assuming that we're all going to try to
get back on the same page to fix
whatever breaks right right so that
bunker is meant to be that way so that
it has thermal mass and therefore my
wines being stored in there don't go bad
even though the power is off for a week
two weeks it's meant it's meant to
house them in that way so they're
they're preserved you sell the wine in
Whole Foods
no I think Whole Foods picked up some of
our stuff at some point but I don't
really make enough wine to really be in
those larger larger chains we make we
might quit a bit but Whole Foods tends
to be like we want to make sure that you
have a [__] load of wine and we always
want to be able to get it
and there's you know there's consistency
with that so you end up with much much
larger larger uh things see I'm here uh
a boutique wine label kind of yeah
we do we're we're at about 15 000 cases
split between four eight Wine Works uh
caduceus and merkin
um which is pretty small compared to
most California wineries how does
Arizona
uh compare it to California California
is like a wine country right yeah the so
the the best way to describe what's
going on in Arizona were high this is
this is geeky stuff now so you're going
to lose your audience but I'm going to
say it anyway because you asked me
Argentina you're familiar with Mendoza
and you have all the model books that
come from that area that elevation and
that that Latitude is is similar to
where we are so as far as high you'll
get snow in the winter and it's high
it's higher altitude
um temperatures and everything are very
similar so if you've ever had an
Argentinian Malbec
I can now you know that we can grow wine
here okay because you know that that
that's possible and then the lava soil
yeah we have we have volcanic soil here
we have a lot of
um Limestone as well because you should
be completely under underwater here
ocean
uh
but as far as
what we end up producing out here that
ends up being strong it's very
Mediterranean so Italian Spanish wines
really really grow well here
California uh they have kind of the more
Bordeaux and burgundy kind of French
soils and climates that kind of back
that up we're more like Italy Spain
southern France Portugal
that's our strength what elevation is
this here we are at I'm gonna get it
wrong because uh Jerome we're uh 4 900
feet down in Cornville or like 3 000
3200 feet so I'm gonna say I think here
we're about 4 100 feet
and that's important when you're farming
elevation oh yeah certain crop
cacao grows like seven to nine thousand
feet yeah Coffee Bean grows at like two
to four thousand feet that's all
fascinating very specific yeah so then
is because of our so but that there's
there's yes and no on that
so if I'm at if I'm at
4 000 feet here
I'm technically compared to California
we're farther south we're closer to the
Equator
so you go oh it's going to be too hot to
grow grapes you've been in Phoenix you
don't bother trying to grow grapes there
but Phoenix is a lower elevation so the
closer you get the Equator the higher in
elevation you have to go so now you get
the cooler temperatures because you're
higher up okay so depending on the
depending on the coffee beans it all
it's yes it's elevation but it's also
latitude where are you
can you grow hydroponic grapes
that's a big facility
yeah it would be a large facility I'm
sure they have but that's that's cost
prohibitive with energy we're just
having to build a huge building to put
your grapes in it that's that's a lot of
infrastructure
is it the Dank huh yeah
[Laughter]
um
the wine is is a crazy world evidently
um so with uh
yoga like every day you start with a
physical exercise it's kind of yeah yeah
I mean just a walk around the vineyard
to begin with just you you watched
walking up this hill was just like it
doesn't matter how many times I walk up
that hill it's like it's you know being
on a StairMaster
for the first uh as in your waking
moments it's right it wins you uh but
you know you know we do the Jiu Jitsu
Academy I'm blending Jiu Jitsu with
actual physical you know warm-ups and
conditioning
Lauren Landau uh Aaron one of his main
guys there out of Denver uh Landau
performance has all these great programs
for strength and conditioning that are
non-invasive you know not injury prone
it's not like no CrossFit if you're
trying to do CrossFit to do like a
professional sport you're an idiot
because you're going to get injured now
you can't do your professional sport
right okay so the more strength and
conditioning stuff that Lauren's doing
is you're getting as in in shape but
you're not risking injury doing it make
sense I'm throwing big ass weights
around and trying to right like running
is generally not really good for you not
great it's not great but like Versa
climbers everyone on one of those Versa
climbers oh my God the things that thing
should be buried in hell yeah great they
have those in Brompton version where you
they Fold It Fold It Up do they put it
in here
the the Versa climber is like this
mean-spirited medieval [__] torture
device that I I love it well how long
has this like uh regimented been like
have you been doing this for I mean I go
in phases you know you go on the road
and you try to maintain that and then
just the hours of you know you're you're
on stage at nine or eight o'clock and
you're not getting off until 11 and you
haven't eaten because I can't eat after
five because I have to go on stage
right so then now now you're eating it
like right midnight which is the dumbest
time to eat and then you gotta go to bed
and a bouncing thing down the highway so
your my workout schedule on the road
just goes to [__] because there's you
can't figure out how to get that now
you're trying to recover by sleeping
till noon yeah do you like the tour bus
life no
do you get to a place do you stay in a
hotel or you stay in the bus
uh it's all about this it's all about
the timing it's all about sleep like
hitting the REM state
yeah if I'm at REM State like if it's
like 5 a.m and the bus can stay where
it's at I don't have to get out of it
I'll stay in the bus to sleep
just so I can get through that that
stage then get up around like eight or
nine and get in the hotel room and
and then but if you go back to bed then
now you're [__] because you're gonna
sleep till two and mm-hmm do you have a
method of calculating your REM sleep
no how do you know dreams uh you know
when they say hey man you want to go in
the hotel I'm like you [__] like you're
like ripped out of the cool hot air
balloon you were floating around the
Amazon River you dick that was it was a
great train okay
um
no I think I think it's just
I can track it more when I'm home
and I know where that state is because I
hit it and then when I wake up refreshed
but in the bus it's like trying to hit
that state it's it's hard because
sometimes it's a long drive and right
when you would be in that state you're
you know you're going through Ohio and
hitting every pothole that was
everything yeah
I have
saw a tool concert I've seen a couple
but the 1996 in Albuquerque New Mexico
Albuquerque
and no I was living there I was so
just I mean not not to crawl up your ass
and and you know smother it with kisses
but I think I think you're looking you
meant to say butthole yeah yeah all
right bring it back I mean there was um
like uh just like the the notes man like
the the like the recreate like there's
certain bands like just aren't great
live and and uh I've found tool to be
unbelievably Stellar live okay and uh I
mean I just
wanted to throw that out there that was
great
what's your point Steve he did great
just let it let it go okay
now I felt my face turning red
hot like how has um performed like like
it's been so many years now like uh
well yeah you know old cars right they
used to like you know an old
uh Barracuda man just like tearing up
the streets you tried to do that with an
old Barracuda now and it's that's
gonna break something's right you know
it just you just can't do that so
think with age you find you find ways
to sing the thing where it's not
creating damage you can actually
recreate it without having to
pick a scab emotionally and literally
like hurting yourself so I think my
writing has changed over the years
um
and I can do some of those songs I can't
do a whole set of those songs right I
can pepper them in so I can still do
some of those things but I can't you
can't
if you're actually sitting down and
thinking about it you can you know you
can't expect
some of those dudes that you know back
in the day to do the thing they did when
they were 30 years ago 40 years ago that
you can't expect that out of that body
your body doesn't do those things
forever
you see the latest uh
latest it was like a year ago Mike Tyson
fighting yeah who do you fight Roy Jones
yeah so as much of a monster as that
dude is and I have all there's respect
and rule for Tyson watching him do that
it's like please please don't do this
ever again yeah because you can see the
age there's a there's a there's an
absolute expiration date on on that high
performance and then at the level that
that guy was operating at when he was in
his prime and to watch whatever that was
right if you don't get it by seeing that
that's the and I'm using him as an
example like that glaring example of
like that is an absolute expiration date
your net your your body is not going to
allow you to perform the way you used to
perform at certain ages so
you can apply that to pretty much
everybody when it comes to physical sure
that's why jackass is gonna be so funny
when they're 70. it's going to be like
the broken hip episode just break in
half um just talking about the stunts
and they break a hip going to get some
get a [__] yogurt for sure right uh
we I have found my bones to be a
considerably more brittle yeah um at
this time and I had the same reaction to
the Mike Tyson fight and and I love Mike
um I was actually at his uh like the
little compound where where he does his
podcast the the Tyson ranch with a bunch
of friends and stuff and
I I felt the same way that you just
described but also it was like a
phenomenally successful event like yes
it wasn't so there's there's and and
that always ends up being the factor
um
money it's just
it twists [__] and you know if
many people that probably have their
hand out
to make money on that fight for Tyson
I'm sure they have their handout again
trying to talk him into doing another
one right when you as a viewer you
remembers you see Anderson Silva connect
dude the other night uh San Hagen and
Cheeto those guys those guys are
lightning fast with those strikes right
and to watch Mike Tyson knowing how fast
he was and then see yeah you can
perceive the micro second delay that he
has to deal with now I said in the intro
that I had the most embarrassing moment
on the podcast ever and I think we can
agree but Man Maynard was cool to save
the day by just talking about how we
lose our virility as we get older and
you know
it's true and that's why I love
Bluetooth because I'm getting older man
it's harder for me to perform all right
now even if you're a young buck turns
out blue cheese actually just a lot of
fun no matter where you're at in your
life it's more fun when you're rocking
Bluetooth why because Bluetooth are
chewable tablets with the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis it's
one ingredient active and man when it
activates it is party time and blue shoe
only costs a fraction of the price of
Viagra and Cialis if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo you can get an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets absolutely
for free all you gotta pay is five bucks
for shipping and they make getting the
prescription super easy because you just
do it with the online medical provider
at bluetooth.com if you're getting older
or if you're not it's more fun with
Bluetooth take my word for it and go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code Stevo
to get an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets totally for free all
you pay is five bucks for shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code Stevo
now let's ride this baby out
compared to that you know compared to
what he was especially when you watch
you know Cheeto and sandhagen fight or
even Chuck the delphot again you know
yeah that is that that's just that was a
tough one
yeah yeah but but but the the money and
and the greed ends up being the factor
that ends up uh
taking a toll on people I mean the older
you get like this this last Australian
tour like really [__] damaged me like
being back home you know like what are
you guys laughing at these guys I mean
out of the country
there's a story I'm kind of I'm gonna
talk to him later
he was able to get into the country but
like
yeah
the 30 the you know the the 20-something
shows in 30 days and like uh I mean we
toured for the last 10 years but like
that like it I can't catch up on sleep
all those different like something's off
this net these like last five days and I
gotta go back in like three or four days
that way it's the easy way it doesn't
matter if the travel the travel part is
going to be the part that just gets you
that's that's why if I can opt to go
from stage into a bed
right these guys go off stage into a
[__] Netflix marathon and stay up to
like three or four but I'm like dude I
have to [__] sleep or I'm dead yeah
by the way thank you for saving me from
that moment where no no we're gonna
we're gonna Circle back oh yeah we're
coming back
so enough about my hair what do you
think about me
um and and thank you for for mentioning
uh UFC God do I [__] love it yeah I
uh I love it so much and um the Cheetos
sandhagen fight it was tough to watch
Judo not get started on that fight like
yeah and you know so that
yeah we can go on for hours on on that
just that idea of
of the armchair jackasses chanting
stupid [__] in the audience having no
[__] idea everything that went into
that fight you have no idea Shiro could
have had the shits that day sure and he
has to deal with that going in so that
that's that
oh a second of timing off for sure for
that night that he has to deal with that
thing and nobody knows about it
he jammed a finger opening a drawer four
hours before you don't know like what's
going on so on that day right San Hagen
had the upper hand that's it next time
they meet
maybe a completely different story it
might be the opposite because those are
both guys operating at the highest level
of the sure thing the guy teaching at
our uh our Academy Clay is our black
belt on site
um he fought MMA and he ended up
breaking his he ended up breaking his
back during training at some point out
in Denver
his last fight he lost a decision
to sanhagen who then got picked up after
that like a fight later he got picked up
by the UFC and hearing him tell stories
of like just what you think what you
think you know about what's happening in
that ring is absolutely
beyond your comprehension in terms of
just the level that they're operating at
right and Sam Hagan particularly with
this switching stances constantly and
coming from every footwork is like
Dominic Cruz and sanhagen have should be
like you know writing code to upload to
us later you watch every UFC I don't
watch all of them I definitely have my
favorite Fighters that I pay attention
to I was extremely extremely extremely
happy for Holly Holm
yeah that was like that that was like so
yeah worried about that one and I to see
her just
who the [__] are you damn yeah she was
great who do you have Stipe or Jon Jones
uh
July 8th oh [__] really I mean I don't
know maybe you just made that yeah I
don't I don't I don't know because uh we
didn't really get a chance to see a lot
from Jon Jones then although
he was training that exact
uh strangle so it could have been a
setup and again that day
yeah the dude across from him didn't he
had he had a just a micro second bad day
that's it right and that changes the
entire fight
um so I mean I wouldn't mind seeing them
fight again
right and I was always been a fan of Jon
Jones I think he's he's his worst enemy
yeah so
we spoke with Alexander volkanovsky when
we were in Australia just a couple days
after the Jon Jones fight and in the UFC
rankings Volk lost his number one pound
per pound to Jon Jones and I submitted
that we didn't get to see enough out of
Jon Jones to uh to Warrant that but then
I doubled back and said you know but the
fact that he made it that easy is
there's a lot to be said for that too so
maybe maybe I can't take that from him
yeah because you know other other than
Jones's own demons and him [__]
himself up over the years
dude he's one of the best yeah I mean I
think the consensus would be that now
that he's the heavyweight champion that
is the best
all right
I think that's the consensus
um I love the that uh yeah have you ever
been tempted to tweet to get your Tweet
on the screen you know I thought about
it and I was like
here's what's gonna happen I'm gonna be
like let me see if they're gonna
oh my [__] God I misspelled that [__]
yeah I'll do something stupid for sure
like I'll put the wrong Fighter's name
up oh my God I did I did one of those
they're pretty good about about not
putting it up if you make a mistake
right what did I say uh
I I got some like uh yeah I always get
it wrong
I'm way too uh
I'm the guy though that like my friends
are all like
there's no way that guy can lose or
that's no way that girl can lose there's
no way they're like they're the best in
the world and I go look
they've won 10 in a row Amanda Nunez
odds are odds are against you even if
you're the best in the world there's
like this weird thing like you're not
allowed to right as good as you are
you're not you're not allowed to win
like 13 in a row or 12 in a row like
there's a number in there that's like no
you don't get to win that one
you will immediately come back and
[__] mangle the person in the next
fight yeah because you are that good but
for some way the universe just it won't
let you have that thing and so there's
so many times that my my buddy just met
him Tim with the flip-flops up there
he's like no there's no way there's no
way that that person is gonna there's no
way the chef shanko's gonna lose like
don't say that I was a lot more
surprised by shevchenko getting caught
by a Grasso than I was uh Nunez getting
caught by Giuliana Pena right because
the next fight right Rosso is gonna go
what happened right because chefchenko's
no joke she's going to make the
adjustment and she's going to fix it
right and unless Grosso keeps up with
that adjustment
it's not gonna happen I think Nunes has
a way of uh getting in her own head like
I think Nunez kind of lost to herself
yes and shevchenko the less inclined to
do that I feel like right so much more
surprising yeah um I uh I watched the uh
volkanovsky Islam fight at Dana White's
house and I asked him two questions I
said what do you think about if uh in
the inspection Zone when you know
they're getting their cup checked and
stuff if they were standing on a scale
so that the viewer could know how much
weight they put on since the official
weigh-in because I'd be interested by
that right and he said that they had
tried that a couple times and that he
didn't like it because uh it drew
attention to weight cutting which they
don't really care to do right I said
okay fair enough how about this his
weight cutting is all full it's gnarly
it's awful yeah it's really gnarly
um I said how about this you know
there's been not much of a debate over
open scoring because nobody's interested
in it like um but what do you think
about at the beginning of round two
round three you know if there's
Championship rounds like at the
beginning of those rounds show what the
live odds are and how the odds have
changed with each round and and Dana
like pulls his phone sends a voice
message to somebody hey Stevo wants live
odds I guess check it out and like
literally from that moment for the rest
of that night every every fight began
with the live box and Dana said you're
not wrong Steve I I like this he's like
Stevo's odds because I was gonna say
they just started doing that is that you
yeah that was me congratulations I like
this adjustment because I was like is
that because I'm I'm watching I see what
I see
and this this number now matches what I
see right they're they're they're not
doing it regularly you know it's not
something that now is in place and I
think they're doing it more I would love
it if they did it all the time as a rule
but I understand
why maybe they wouldn't want to do that
because it indicates more of a blowout
fight making it you know the the
illusion of uh
but it was during the the chefchenko
grazo fight I texted Dana uh live odds
please and we got him right away right
and I thought Grosso was looking really
good in that first round but going into
round two the the the Gap had swollen
and it said uh chefchenko was minus one
thousand uh yeah and I remember seeing
that going that's not what I just said
that was not what I saw either I was
surprised and that that minus 1000
chefchenko live odds made Grasso
finishing her that round so much more uh
satisfying and yeah like uh maybe just
so much more unlikely and and
awesome that's sick yeah we could talk
about fighting on the hours all night I
love it we should steer the focus over
to Vinnie for a little while now oh God
I I do feel that I owe it to you to tell
you about Vinnie's prison pocket well we
have a couple different ideas
we have a spiritual story or a prison
Pocket story let's take a pic I have a
feeling this somehow intersect
sort of
Vinnie recently became our our co-host
and his grade he's colorful he he uh and
and he just had this experience a guy
came up to him in public yeah he died to
tell the story I was at the gym working
out and uh after working out I went to
go to this restaurant in the same
parking lot and
I finished eating I get back in my car
and I see this Indian dude maybe late
40s early 50s walk by my car turns his
head locked and he just locks eyes with
me
stops him in his track and just go
excuse me sir you have a very lucky and
happy face and at first I thought this
dude was like a kook you know just like
absolutely crazy and he comes over to my
car he's like no we're supposed to meet
here at this very moment
and I'm like okay this dude is
definitely a cook first
and then he grabs my wrist right and he
and as soon as he grabs my wrist I get
this like intense feeling of like pins
and needles you described it as heroin
but I described it as a magnified heroin
High just times a thousand and um
and he starts missing a liver
and uh and he's like he kept saying
we're supposed to meet here at this at
this moment and he takes out this piece
of paper out of his pocket and he's like
put this hold this tight in your right
hand and don't let go okay like I'm
really in this now you know and uh he's
like he's like you were uh you were
meant to be on this Earth your purpose
is making people laugh and making people
happy and um he's like what I want you
to do is tell me a relation a female
relationship in your life that's been
bringing negative energy and the first
thing that came in my my mind was my mom
so I just said my mom's name
and then he's like names her maiden name
and what's the last four of you
yeah and then and then he goes like he's
like name the first kind of flower that
comes to your head so I say lilies he
goes what uh what year did your mother
birth I said 87. he goes what do you
want to do and what are you doing now
he's like I would like to do some TV
stuff and uh then he just goes on saying
like
again we were here to we were we were
meant to meet here you uh you are on the
right path like everything you're doing
is the right thing keep doing what
you're what you're doing you need to
stop thinking so much you need to stop
planning so much I just do and he goes
touch that piece of paper to your
forehead and open it up I touch that
[__] to my forehead and open it up it
has my mom's name 1987 lilies and TV see
that's where the story throws me off
because like that's part of like Hokey
magic tricks you know like and then she
had the paper in his head yeah
you have that experience and for you to
poo poo whatever that is whatever magic
came next for him sure based on that
experience right if this guy stole his
car and it's his identity yeah now we
got a problem but whatever that is and I
have I have friends that you know that
believe in ghosts they believe in those
things they believe in Tarot Card those
things I [__] love the stories of
that
if that inspires you to be kinder or
better or more constructive with your
life with somebody else's life 100 in
but if you ask me honestly that
[__] had your number
I'm kind of in the same corner too but
it's like yeah you can Google my birth
my birthday like you could find that
[__] out but how how's this dude gonna
know that I'm gonna say lilies right and
that's where the camera recording of the
bill from the building
that's not a bad idea okay and the more
compelling part of the story I think
superheroes are real a dude that's
really fast wrote ran around the
building wrote it on the piece of paper
and put it in his hand and you couldn't
see him he was so fast yeah I I find the
most compelling piece of the story the
physical Sensation that came over your
body when he touched it yeah and and
then an uncontrollable sobbing like I
couldn't stop crying and I it was almost
like my heart was skipping beats and I
couldn't move and then after he after he
just says he leaves I'm sobbing
uncontrollably and then I turn around
and he's just gone
and it was I so many emotions were going
through my head like I'm [__]
terrified that was I'm kind of stoked I
was sick I don't know what to do I'm
texting him I'm like dude I'm freaking
out like like people call them worried
about them yeah after he left those
people in on it no no [__] way
and you you're an immediate response was
I think I might have just had a
conversation with god that's why I
texted him that was the first thing I
can't take that away from you yeah
yeah and and so uh State he says where
was this uh in Ella okay yeah what would
Michael Jordan be doing in La yeah
and the next day the one thing that he's
been dreaming of the most
all right I'm Dreaming but working hard
he wanted to be verified on Instagram so
bad for the next day yeah yeah
congratulations
Australian Visa came through despite the
fact that he is a intent to sell drug
dealer
in your pocket heroin addict
congratulations on all of those things
you used to live in a porta potty
yeah yeah so he went to prison for six
months he knew he was going what a
Segway nice so you talked to Michael
Jordan in L.A
but I went to prison yeah before that
and and then going knowing that he was
checking himself in for six months in
jail are you cool about talking about
yeah yeah this is fine
[Music]
mellow he knew he was gonna be dope sick
so he went for the prison pocket and
what did you fit in there uh a
hypodermic needle
10 Xanax bars a thing of Rolling Papers
maybe two grams of tobacco and enough
dope to last me a couple weeks I still
got five more fingers yeah
I would I wouldn't put this that's it I
would have been
advantages yes
some Brazilian coffee beans
yeah
but um
Vinnie's past and and now Vinny's
recently celebrated five years of
sobriety
killing it doing like from where he was
he's on the right path doing the right
thing and this this magical Michael
Jordan character told him don't think so
much don't plan so much everything's
gonna work out in the in the months of
April May and July April May July you're
gonna your life is gonna change
radically for the better yeah and I'm
rooting for you dude well thanks dude I
love it I want it all to be true yeah me
too yeah and the fact that you got to
tell that story but if it's not true if
it doesn't go the way that that was
described take that as a challenge to
make it go that way for sure and the way
that I think of it it's just more of
like
as long as I just continue like being
the best version of myself every day
things work out without any explanation
I don't know how it's just that's how
it's been happening the last couple
years and every year it's just been
better and better so
that's just what I'm gonna do you are a
special person
Vinnie's Vinnie's a Manifesto and he's a
very special person yeah I believe
having a manifestation yeah yeah and
I've always found 35. yeah you're there
you're lucky that yeah you figured out
how to make those things happen when
does it start happening for you
uh
right around 28
I started realizing that there's ways
that I could not you know not manipulate
time and space it's not like that it's
just more more paying attention to
decisions that I already made and
building on what recognizing that
decision process and recognizing that
feeling in your gut combined with the
experiences that you have logged up in
your computer like combining experience
with intuition to make decisions but
also going I can't make the wrong
decision right there's it's going to
lead to some
uh educational conflict or some success
that I can then build on for more
more good or bad decisions they're just
decisions and you go forward yeah do you
have a book that changed your life
um
besides doomsday prepping but like not
doomsday prepping uh yeah I wrote a lot
of I read a lot of uh Joseph Campbell
back in college and things like that uh
but honestly it was just
just experiences watching paying
attention to not just my own experience
but my other other friends experiences
and just seeing what they went through
for decisions that they made and letting
go of things that didn't matter I think
that's the that's the biggest
man it just
if you can get to the point where you
can understand what to let go of
like imagine how fun the internet would
be
if people knew how to just let go of
[__]
and not engage and just fight to the
death over the dumbest [__] hilarious
[__] ever
yeah yeah it's just and it's all about
that it's all that age of like no I have
to win this fight with a stranger yeah
on the opposite side of the globe over
[__] pizza recipes or whatever and on
the flip side of that if you can let go
of uh you know for me the over developed
concern for the opinions of others
if I didn't you know right if I wasn't
so gripped by fear of what you know
people think of me or they're so hurt by
a negative comment right oh yeah that's
but you're but you're you're exposed
like I am in that way like you you take
that seriously because you are an
introspective person and you care
you're a caring person so you're gonna
you're gonna take some of that on just
that's just your nature uh but being
able to take a deep breath in those
moments and let that [__] go yeah it's
[__] hard but it's essential
yeah that easy and for where you you
were saying
um my experience has been that when I
get so stressed out I'm trying to force
something to happen and it's like ah
like uh if I can just turn my
attention and my energy to the the work
of recovery everything else sorts itself
out yeah 100 like oh yeah like you know
am I am I doing the work of recovery if
I do that then I don't have to worry
about anything I was reading a book last
night you squared it talked about a fly
just kept hitting the window and hitting
the window he just kept hitting the
window and then he just finally just
that he'll do that until he dies and all
he has to do is just turn around and go
the other way and he can go right into
the door easily and the wind will take
him so it's like don't force anything
you know yeah that that was a really
interesting and the wind will take him
that's the craziest part wow
um my uh meditation app every once in a
while it says uh
um
by uh struggling to paddle like well
inevitably drown but if we just relax we
float
yeah
like a high fiber turd yeah like a high
five return
um that is true but you know circling it
back around to the UFC and doing martial
arts and everything that's some of the
guys as you watch those dudes get higher
up in Jiu Jitsu they're so relaxed yeah
because they understand
that the more this young dude who's just
stressing out trying to win
30 seconds this guy's going to be so
gassed because he's just he's wasting
all of his energy rather than just like
relaxing into the moment to go if I put
my hand here where does this extremely
experienced
black belt put his hand where's he move
his foot where does he shift his weight
based on me doing a thing to see what
he's doing rather than me like I learned
a dance move on YouTube and I'm going to
try to force the dance move right you're
just wasting your time you got to pay
attention to what this guy who has
experience is going to do in reaction to
you reaching with his hand or reaching
with his hand or whatever and that
relaxing that's the wind understanding
that yeah other than beating up against
the glass that's you got to just get a
good bend with band with the wind I mean
you had to get really good at that being
a farmer like oh you have no idea
zero zero all the plans in the world and
then you get hail your [__] crops
toast mm-hmm so you just have to you
have to go this is what I've got this is
what I got this year this is what we're
doing
and when you plant the seed hurry up and
grow what the [__] are you doing nothing
gonna happen you just gotta forget about
it there's a there's there's I cannot
make the grapes be ripe in you know
April
they're going to be ripe in August
September there's nothing you can do to
force that issue so that patience and
let go let God kind of thing that's
farming man it's to a T
um how much uh why is it that wine they
say like age like a fine wine is that
real like wine gets better the older it
is uh yeah that's old yeah you don't
have enough Italians okay yeah yeah well
it's it's it's about the the the
complexity that is that living breathing
creature in a bottle it changes over
time and the more uh TLC that went into
the actual growing of those grapes and
then the ushering and Those Grapes into
that state of being a wine
they have a they have a structure that
is built to age and change and become
more complex with age there's definitely
a peek to it then it falls off but like
there is there is a
an understanding of wine making and
grape growing that kind of goes into
that statement that gets lost with just
the Aging lack of Fine Wine well if you
want if you want to understand all the
effort to took into cultivating that
vine and all the effort that it takes to
coax that fruit off that vine in the
most the best expression of that day
that year
and then put it in that bottle that
getting in the way and not manipulating
it you know that's where I'm going to
come from it from that metaphorical
you know steward
I'm not a I'm not a winemaker I'm a
steward of the grape just getting it
from grape to to wine
all right
um
uh Puscifer
like is is it an imminent release or it
already
uh the so every time we do a full-length
album we then go back and we reach out
to all of our friends and they have a
reimagining of all the tracks and so
that's being released uh March 31st is
Friday this Friday from the day after
this comes out perfect yeah so that'll
be out in the market uh you know all the
all the formats final CD remember
compact discs and
um
streaming digital all that it's pretty
fun like we got a lot of cool people to
kind of do it this time uh it's always
nice to hear
what people are gonna reimagine these
things so quite a few uh
Justin uh Chancellor from Tool did one
uh Ocarina in the band my favorite was
Karina's track
um but Trent uh and Atticus did one
uh Sarah Jones drummer for uh Harry
Styles okay Sarah did one
um she was actually on the she played a
lot on the actual album our album uh we
were trying to get her to go on tour
with us but she's out with Harry like
she's like permanent fixture in that
whole thing so we kind of lost her
Harry is doing pretty well yeah
there's you know there's no reason to
rock that boat she's killing it with uh
with the band so there's no reason to uh
bust his balls if I want to
um because she's great I just I wanted a
tour with her but uh yeah he got her
um
who else is on there uh Matt Mitchell
did one uh Troy van lewen from Queen's
stone age did one
uh I'm gonna forget about the people
that did one Phantogram did one so it's
quite it's it's quite a fun lineup of
Juliet commager who's also one of the
vocalists that worked with Lucifer all
the time she did one they're all great
they're just it's just really nice to
hear them completely reimagined yeah
um is there uh you were talking about
catching up on touring has that just
happened or is that about to happen oh
man I've been touring since
uh 22
started because like we were shut the
[__] down right 20 and 21 with all bands
and so and now everybody's out and we're
all out and we're out so like I'm I'm
going I'm on the road again and in a few
weeks with Puscifer and Tool
wow for all summer and then tool back
out in the fall
and then tool back out in the winter
and then I'm trying to do my I turn 60
and uh uh 20 24.
so I'm gonna try to put together a thing
I did it for my 50th birthday called
shinkuanta where we're gonna do say
Santos on my 60th
birthday show in some way I'm trying to
figure out what to do I look older than
you do yeah you do yeah yeah
that's the lack of sleep
could be yeah yeah it's uh I mean it's
pretty remarkable the way you've kept
yourself together
yeah you gotta look you gotta look under
the hood that's a mess
yeah yeah um and then now when you're
going out on these tours like uh it is a
bus operation
yeah so for Puscifer we're gonna do
uh Tool's got a couple festivals in May
same same Festival as Opus playing
luckily not the same night because I
would [__] murder me but uh we'll be
in a bus and then in Europe it'll be
probably like crew will have two buses
bam will have one bus or some
combination of that so the entire band
all the wrestlers all the all of our you
know everybody on one bus and then the
crew on another bus and then um
tool it's like
me and my dog yeah
your dog likes the RV uh she you know
she doesn't mind it
um she's kind of young
she's she's learning learning the road
my uh beloved Wendy just does he's
scared of the bus I couldn't bring her
anymore she just gets stressed out yeah
I want to have her and I just couldn't
do it so I got a Yorkie so she just sits
right here and there you go she's fine
um I think that we could probably wrap
it up and I I know I'm going to say this
in the intro to the podcast but uh man
thank you so much like what an honor and
um I I've never deployed this bus just
to do a podcast like uh okay it's epic I
remember the one time we we took our
podcast who are you running into in
Vegas uh Steve Aoki oh okay I don't know
Steve but hello Steve yeah and uh I just
they were last minute uh text to Dana's
if he wants to uh you know which um it's
just rude he's been nothing but kind to
me whenever I kind of like reach through
the through the powers of B to like
because there's a particular fight that
I want to be there for yeah I don't I
don't I try not over the years I've
tried not to milk that through our
booking agent to like be the guy that
wants tickets to everything the only
thing I ever
beg for is that front row for UFC it's
unbelievable it's the greatest in the
world I was there for in Phoenix when uh
when Nate almost caught I was there for
that oh my god dude like that was like
I'm I'm like literally like a freaking
out like a meth head like on the on the
sideline just screaming going finishing
I was in the fighter section for that
okay like uh which was fun in its own
right
um yeah dude it's it's so great man and
and I will pass that on to to Dana
um I'm sure that he's super stoked to
have you there you know who's the most
rabid UFC fan is Anthony Kiedis really
yeah I've uh I went to an event with my
girl in Dallas and we're psycho you
should come train at our Academy I I
don't doubt that he would
um down I uh my girl and I get to the
fight this was when Tyron Woodley fought
Darren till in Dallas
we come in there for the first fight
pass prelim because we're like that's
just how we do it we sit there and we're
gonna sit there for six hours and and we
walk out there in the first fight and
Anthony Kiedis and already in the sea
yeah and I'm sitting right next to it
because some of the best fights you're
gonna see you're gonna be those prelims
because paying attempt pay attention to
what they're doing
uh you're going to see them again if
they're any good yeah it was Irene
aldana on the uh on the Fight Pass
prelims that night and I remember I sat
down to Anthony cages I was like I'm not
gonna bug him like just shut up just be
cool you know and like and and Anthony
is he's like oh dude we're like you know
talking about fighting the whole time it
was the most fun I've ever had at the
UFC it's awesome just broing down with
Anthony Kiedis that was behind Vitor
Belfort's massive skull
and I'm like trying to watch this
Anderson Silva fight and that's when
Weedman broke his leg uh uh Anderson
broke his leg I was like behind I
watched it Go and I'm like oh
yeah
that's a tough one yeah I was there when
when Connor broke his leg
Yeah well yeah dude
um it's just it's an incredible honor
um I I don't know that I've been more
excited ever for one of these so thank
you thank you
what's your point Steve
I just write poems dude
is this about my hat
I love it man oh uh do you tell them
about our driver
I've been tour bus driver I told him uh
right when the idea first came up I was
like oh man like uh you know end of
March beginning April we're gonna go to
Arizona and you know for for Maynard and
our bus driver said I sold him his
property
33 years ago and
in Arizona Arizona what's his name Bruce
Bruce what he's right outside the door
I saw I bought several properties when I
first
Robison so probably worse and thinner he
probably it was probably up in uh on the
mountain
30 Acres up on Mingus Mountain Mingus
that's what he said yeah third the 32
yeah
he's coming in yeah Bruce is the best
um Calvin said and I was like oh I want
to tell Maynard on the you know like get
his reaction while we're recording and
and uh he said yeah like you're gonna
get a bit way bigger reaction from the
Brompton
but yeah the like um
the uh you know the odds so so the 30
Acres on Mangus yeah okay
and this happened like 30 years ago yeah
well it happened in 1997-98
problem yeah yeah that was the because
that was a it was payments and a balloon
payment at the end yeah yep that was a
great piece of property yep
yeah I regret selling it but I made a
lot of money off it so yeah
well I ended up using it to buy another
piece that uh I have Vineyards on so it
was a wise move for me because I
couldn't plant Vineyards on that part
but I ended up flipping it to to get
this other piece in Cornville that ended
up it's you know it's one of my favorite
sites
yeah dude cool right on man all right
well that that that's a wrap and I get I
have a do you have a CD player in here
uh do we have a CD player in here
uh I don't know how many of you guys
have gotten a CD gifted to you from
Maynard but I think that's a pretty big
deal
let me uh say too I was gonna say this
in the intro but I just didn't have the
heart but uh
when I filled out my application to
clown college they weirdly asked a bunch
of crazy questions like when is the last
time you cried and why and like it was
just weird and among the questions was
what your three favorite musical acts
and number one that was tool I put it on
on my clown college application in 1997
and you know the footage of me drinking
the bong water that might have been 90
no that was 97 too but uh I mean they
were talking a long time ago man like
big time fan and that was huge plus let
me tell you that uh Steve Aoki like one
of my favorite people in the world now
like absolutely the Steve Aoki podcast
was
fantastic and that's not even coming
next next week is a complete surprise
out of nowhere I'll tell you it's Lisa
Vanderpump come but like my friendship
with Lisa Vanderpump is pretty epic
we're we're really gonna we're going
into a fun time with this podcast and
you know how much I love you guys for
sticking around and um I love you even
more for not judging me on what a dork I
was on that one